hi everyone it's Jerry I have an
excellent game to share with you from
1977.
this was played in Cambridge
Massachusetts between the Greenblatt
chess program on the white end and Bobby
Fischer
so this was five years after Fisher
became world champion
the Greenblatt chess program began being
developed at MIT in 1966 and it was
named after the computer programmer
Richard greenblatt
now as with any emerging technology
this program had its Skeptics one in
particular Hubert Dreyfus a professor of
philosophy
he made the claim that computers
wouldn't be able to play high quality
chess and well
he was beaten by this very program
this program really marked the start of
respectable computer chess play
now the game I'm highlighting in this
video is one of three Fisher played
against this program
it's the one I found most interesting
most instructive and the one I think is
of the highest quality
at the end of the video I'll share what
today's top engine has to say
about green Flats play
the game kicks off with E4 a move Fisher
himself has described as best by test
so we're certainly off to a good start
C5 on board the Sicilian Defense G6
takes us into the hyper accelerated
dragon
D4 Bishop G7
black is not concerned about losing a
pawn it could always be regained with
Queen A5 check and there you go
Knight C3
Fischer now breaks up the pawn Duo
and challenges the Knight on D4 one of
the main ideas
with this hyper accelerated dragon is to
not be so quick to obstruct the fiend
cut out Bishop's eyes
it remains open to White side of the
board and these two minor pieces are now
intersecting on D4
white must tend to this and does so in
the best way with Bishop E3
only now comes Knight F6
Knight takes Knight
Fischer takes towards the center
and the Knight is questioned
there are two options here
Knight D5 would go into a Gambit line or
Knight G8
what's the idea with Knight to D5
well you give up this pawn and you're
looking forward to play on the queen
side as well as development with tempo
there is compensation for black in this
line
the decision by Fisher is to Simply go
back home this is regarded as best
at the same time the bishop is back to
seeing the world E5 is hit
F4 what is F4 doing it sounds it's going
to sound very simple but F4 is defending
E5
there's a reason I'm saying this in a
simple way I'll be drawing some
attention to the F4 move in just a
little bit
okay
there's a White Pond in Black's house a
good strategy challenge it as soon as
possible
and if you could do so with a flank Pawn
F6 does just that
this is not the only way to go as black
with E5 in the F5 square has been
weakened so this night looking to get
there
you know this path is appealing and a
little bit later black could maybe
consider playing F6 or D6
in this game it is challenge D5 is
challenged right away
the reply is to capture on F6 and with
this move there is however slight a
shift in the evaluation a shift in the
assessment
it's not a grave error but
it's considered better to maintain
control over E5 with Bishop to D4 or
look to play in Gambit Style with the
move E6 now at the time I don't believe
the chess programs back then were
prepared to play a move like E6 and give
up a pawn like this because
too great a weight was still being
placed on material
now the masters of today would certainly
see better of this E6 move and know that
you know there is compensation in the
form of this lead in development
and white has ideas to
post up a night on C5 a bishop on C4 and
we could really start to see that this
E6 Pawn will be in the crosshairs and
probably just drop off
and what will remain in the end is white
with the superior structure
Black's Queen side is a wreck split
isolated pawns they will be a sore spot
for probably the duration of the game
one other note with this E6 move D5 is
considered the best response with F5 to
follow and it gets a little crazy this
is one to examine more closely if you're
interested with this structure it's not
the norm to be sure here's a funny line
if you try and capture the pawn you're
gonna get mated as black so careful
Queen H5 Queen F7 game over
mate on the weakest Square in Black's
camp
in any event
the reply to F6 is to Simply give up
this Pawn on E5
black recaptures the Knight the king
Knight Returns to its favorite Square
and now I have a question
in this position about the F4 Pawn just
moments ago I said something that
sounded really basic I said F4 what is
it doing defending the E5 Pawn
what is this guy doing now
I don't know
in a way there is a bit of an
inconsistency here F4 was played Just
moments ago to guard an E5 Pawn that's a
positive but now there isn't an E5 Pawn
there what purpose does it serve in this
position
it remains to be seen I believe F4 is
now mostly a negative
is mostly seen as a negative look at the
gaps there are weaknesses on E3 E4 both
are holes
all right with every pawn move
it carries a positive and negative I
believe F4 is mostly now seen as a
negative
okay
game continues with Bishop C4
not really the best move
it's right around this stage of the game
that fisher now seizes the initiative
D5 white is running right into this
productive move
black is able to establish upon in the
center with an attack The Bishop's eyes
are opened this was not a good move to
allow well this initial deployment to C4
was not best a more stable Square on E2
was preferable
now it goes back to E2
now Rook to B8
B2 is hit and defended
with B3
this is where white is going astray
there are some
tactical liabilities now the Knight on
C3 after this last move it's unprotected
this diagonal is weakened with b3n this
Bishop's eyes
have become really wide
there's something here
now one of the better decisions at this
point a better way to meet Rook to B8
is to defend B2 indirectly Bishop to D4
the ID to meet Rook takes B2 with Knight
takes on D5
Okay computer was not quite there at the
time B3 straight away
and now in comes Knight to G4 this
initiative continues
the night is hit the bishop is hit
there's no time to take the Knight
if you take the knight in this position
they would follow Bishop takes Knight
check
Bishop D2
the bishop takes Bishop Queen takes
Bishop
and Bishop takes rook and if you've lost
count
black is up a full Rook
okay in short this Knight is poison
the best way to meet these two threats
is with the move played in the game
Bishop D4
and now an excellent decision by Fisher
E5
I want to draw some attention to this
point in the game
the best move
is in the computer's eyes to play into
E3
and I have no doubt that fisher
certainly saw that this was a move
but discarded it
and let me Express why I think that
E5 I think is the best human approach in
this position
let's have a look at this Knight E3 move
what is it doing it's hitting the queen
this Knight must be captured straight
away
if white is simply reacting to the
thread on the queen with let's say queen
D3 this is a loss straight away with
Bishop takes Bishop
Queen takes bishop and black would be
able to land this beautiful Fork The
Queen Is Lost
so Knight to E3 would be best met with
Bishop takes Knight
and then Bishop takes Rook however for a
human this is difficult to play
because there are serious dark Square
weaknesses in Black's camp
and white has an unopposed dark Square
Bishop and we could see this one piece
being
a master of the board for example if it
gets to E5 how is that really a
three-point piece
it would dominate the whole board
so there are problems there are safety
issues there would be safety issues for
Black's King if he chose this path if he
was of a materialistic mentality if he
had a materialistic mentality Fisher did
not at this point in the game he's not
playing Knight to E3 instead it's E5
he's shutting down this diagonal or I
should say he's not so quick to exchange
dark Square Bishops he's more interested
in prying open the position
he's getting at this f-pawn
he's making uh he's forcing white to
make this decision and now he is able to
do what
not just recapture on E5 but get castled
before it's too late
there's a race here to see who could get
castled
if black simply recaptures the pawn look
what happens white gets to Castle
and stop black from castling you can't
Castle through check
but
by castling right now it's black that's
doing the same to White
is not able to Castle straight away
now this Knight is hanging but with the
tactic it could be one back and we see
just that Bishop takes Knight follows
Queen H4 check
the bishop is one back we are 18 moves
in the game no Queens on board an end
game is present
it is an even position
this is where White NOW goes wrong
and
plays Rook to F1
it's not immediately clear it wasn't
immediately clear to me why this was a
grave error
um considered
best in this position is to play H3
what is the idea to try and kick the
bishop off of this diagonal
so that the king can Castle queenside
so for example this queen side castles
and we go from here it's still a game
if the bishop tries to meet H3 with
Bishop F3 staying on the diagonal well
now the Rook isn't guarding F1 and white
would be able to Castle kingside
Whitey's doing well in this position
white is the better side
okay as mentioned this is where white
goes wrong after Rook to F1 it's now a
losing position for white
after Rook takes Rook King takes Rook
black now has only one move that wins
Can you spot the winning move
Fisher played in this position
if you'd like to go ahead pause the
video see if you can find White's best
okay the winning move here
is C5
and this kicks the Bishop from its
defense of E5
White's Position will now collapse the
weakness that was created
on C3 the weakness that Rook B8 provoked
there's going going to now be a problem
on the long diagonal
in the game
Bishop F1 excuse me Bishop F2 is played
what happens if the bishop captures the
pawn well
the bishop captures E5 and not only is
this Knight unprotected but it's pinned
to The Rook
and there's no way to defend it
black will soon win a piece
so in the game the bishop goes to F2 the
idea
to meet Bishop takes Pawn with defense
of the Knight this is a nice try however
a couple moves
down the line we're going to see that
this
pin of the night can be taken advantage
of
The Rook is no longer needed on the B
file it gets to the f file with check
and The Rook is able to now pivot on
that intersection Square F3
from here is H3 Rook takes Knight Bishop
takes Rook
there's no time in this position to take
the bishop
since Rook C2 would hit with check and
then the Rook would fall
so as Bishop takes Rook Bishop takes
Bishop
hitting the Rook
and Rook to F1 Bishop F5 let's pause for
a moment
it's an imbalanced state
two Bishops versus The Rook
white really has no chance though
there's no way to compete against these
two Bishops no counter play for white
this Rook unfortunately will have to
play
a completely passive role from this
stage on there's no way to activate it
there's a problem on C2 as well so The
Rook has to take up this defensive post
on F2
there are no tricks by the way
for white with let's say G4
allowing this capture and trying to hit
black with the skewer because there are
ways out Bishop E4 check and next you
could save the dark Square Bishop
so in this game it's Rook F2 straight
away
It's The End Game Time to improve the
king towards the center not so fast
you'd be walking into a pin G4 would hit
and white would be winning of course
Fisher is not allowing that
what does he play H5
stabilizes the bishop does not allow
G4
this light Square Bishop is doing
a number on white
it is tying down the king and Rook to a
defensive role the bishop keeps pressure
on H3 the king must defend
it's putting pressure on C2 The Rook
must defend
a sad position for team white from here
and the technique is very very clean by
Fisher at this at this point in the game
the king could now approach he's now
walking into a pin
Bishop backs off
gets out of the PIN
The Bishop's hit but now this C Pawn
can be hit D4 is nearby and black will
soon be creating a past Pawn
two Bishops a past pawn and King The
Rook is no match
from here the past Pawn simply advances
it's defended the promotion square is
hit
and nice clean technique from here
look at how these Bishops are used
Bishop D4
where does the king ideally want to be
in the end game in the center but
it can no longer go in the center it
must be demoted it goes to G2
lacks in a spot to promote but he wants
the full Queen he doesn't want to allow
The Rook to sacrifice itself for the
pawn
so he simply improves the king
King's able to walk all the way up and
eventually white is in a restricted
State the King has to play this
defensive role and when you're in this
defensive position you are vulnerable to
a deflection we see just that with
Bishop H3
The Rook is one black is able to promote
and give mate in just a couple
Queen G2 game
over
so a very nice game this one here
let's have a look at the tail of the
tape and we could see the quality of
play by both sides
as we can see going into this one
there's some dip right about here after
Rook B8
B3 was played
it's pointing out Bishop D4 would have
been better then it gets back up to even
18 moves in playing against
Fisher
an even game and that Rook to F1 move in
the end eventually there was this C5
idea and only move that
uh gave Fisher a decisive advantage and
from there it was just a matter of
technique the two Bishops versus The
Rook uh you're not going to win that one
at the end of the day Fisher was playing
with a 97 percent accuracy and the green
black chess program
coming in at an 87 accuracy
anyhow as usual feel free to leave any
feedback to this video in the comments
section below
I hope you enjoyed it and maybe took a
thing or two away that's all for now
take care bye
thank you